Let's consider examples
of our principle
that the external
torque about a point, s,
causes the angular momentum
of a system to change about s.
We've examined
central force problems
in which we chose the point s
to be the central point in which
there was no torque.
Now, as examples,
let's look at a case
where we have a pivoted object.
So I could take an
example of an object.
Let's see, this will be overhead
view of a ring of radius r.
And I'm going to have
a mass coming in.
I'll call this ring
mass m1, this object m2.
This object is coming in
with an initial velocity,
and this is my pivot point.
Now, when the object
m2 is hitting the ring,
we have a force, F2 on 1.
This is the collision.
Here's our pivot point.
And when this hits
the ring, we'll
have some type of pivot force.
I'm just going to
denote the pivot force.
We're not quite sure
what it will point at,
but I'll just say F
pivot, for the moment,
is holding this point in place.
At the same time, the object
will have a force, F1,2,
acting on the object.
Here is our pivot point, p.
And now, what point should we--
should we choose to see if
there's no torque [? about? ?]
Suppose we choose
the pivot point.
Well-- p.
Well, clearly, the pivot force
has no torque about the pivot,
because the vector from
the pivot point to where
the pivot force is acting is 0.
Remember, pivot forces have no
torque about the pivot point.
However, this collision
force will produce
a torque about the pivot.
And that's-- the angular
momentum of the ring is not
constant, because the
ring will start to rotate.
Similarly, this
object is reversing--
will reverse
directions, or will do
something due to the collision.
And again, this force will
produce a torque that's equal
and opposite to the
torque on the ring.
This is the torque
on the particle.
But if we make our system equal
to the particle and the ring--
so we'll call this, our system
is now both the particle
and the ring--
then these torques are
internal, and because they're
equal and opposite
forces, the rs vector
is exactly the same rs vector.
The internal torques
cancel in pairs.
The pivot force
produces no torque.
So the torque on the system
about the pivot is 0.
And that tells us that
the angular momentum
of the system about
that pivot point,
initially, will be equal
to the angular momentum
about that pivot point,
finally, if we take
two initial and final states.
In particular, suppose
our initial state is--
here's the pivot.
Our object is coming
in, that was m2 vi.
The moment arm is r.
And our vector from here
to the object, rs initial,
has a moment component that way.
If we put these
vectors tail to tail
and figure out that the
angular momentum is pointing
in this direction, l initial
i, and the moment arm is r,
then the initial angular
momentum about this pivot point
is just due to
this moving object.
So that's m2 vi, and
the moment arm is r,
and we'll denote its
direction that way.
Now, the final
angular momentum--
let's imagine that it sticks.
So we have m2, pivot,
and now our ring
is going to be rotating
with some omega final
because this object hits it.
And notice that this
object is a distance
root 2 r from the pivot point.
So the final angular momentum
can be two different pieces.
You can think of this
as a system, where
we have I of the system
about p times omega final,
because now it's
just a rigid body.
And the angular
momentum of the system
is consisting of two pieces.
It's the angular
momentum of the ring
about the pivot,
plus the angular
momentum of the particle about
the pivot, times omega final.
Now, this is the center of mass.
This is the pivot point, p.
The angular momentum of the
ring is the angular momentum
about the center of-- we'll
use the parallel axis theorem--
angular momentum about
the center of mass,
plus the distance from
the center of mass
to the parallel axis,
which is a distance, r.
So the first piece is Icm
ring plus m r squared.
And the angular momentum
about the particle,
this is going in a
circle of radius r2--
root 2r, so when
we square that--
by the way this was,
mass of the ring was 1.
Mass of the particle
was m2 times r squared,
which is this distance
squared, which is
2 r squared times omega final.
The moment of
inertia of the ring
is m1 r squared about
the center of mass.
We have the factor 2.
We have another factor of 2.
And so we get m1 plus
m2 times a factor 2 r
squared omega final,
which we can call omega
f, pointing out of the board.
And so now, we have an
angular momentum condition,
which is that m2 vi r
equals 2 m1 plus m2 r
squared omega final.
And that is the statement
that the initial angular
momentum of our system--
the ring is at rest here--
is equal to the final angular
momentum of the system, where
m2 is stuck to the
ring, and they're
all rotating about this
pivot point with omega final.
That's the angular
momentum of the system
about p, omega final.
This is the initial
angular momentum.
And so I can conclude that
omega final is m2 vi over 2
m1 plus m2 times r.